[Music]
hello everybody I would like to welcome
those who join us for
tonight's lesson
uh I would like to show you uh
how to prepare to the game
preparation is very important
in the chess player alive
and
you you can
prepare at home you can solve puzzles
you can watch tournaments or the plate
by strongest
by top players in the world
you can analyze your own games
but how
you can prepare to the game
played in the particular tournament
one of the examples is my game
I played in the first U.S Senior
championship in 2019
versus
Grandmaster Max doggie
I don't play much
recent years
so I don't follow the theory
and
it's very hard to play in the
tournaments after long long break
in this
game
I played with black
and during uh
the game preparation
I paid attention with the max is playing
a lot of games online
and many players who
play online
play D4 D5
Bishop
for variation
this variation became very popular
nowadays
and initial task of this a move was to
avoid the theory but now when
thousands of games
having played
by this line online even
this array of variation
has its own Theory
during uh
preparation before the game
I paid attention
that
Max
was foreign to the games played by
another
very strong online player
you can know him uh
under the Nick penguin
and one of the Android tank games
was very interesting and I found
extremely nice idea
so
I decided to analyze the line and to go
uh to that idea I played Knight F6
E3
C5
here uh there are a few
Alliance white I can play Knight F3
nice C3
also C3 is possible
but uh Andrew tank played DTX C5
trying to grab the pawn
on C5 now
there are a few
opportunities
for black
uh
the usual move here's 96 prevention
before
but here it was necessary to calculate
the
Bishop B5
position
is very similar with reverse color
uh Queen's gun that
position and now
white is trying
to protect a pound on C5
the main line here is Queen A5 check
Knight CS3
now
this rate is
A3 and before
and a black has to hurry
so A6
Bishop J is B6 Bishop 66 b66
uh
24
it seems that
white has
a huge Advantage because there is no
defense out of before move
but
here black has his counter play he can
play E6
and now what to do
if before
then Queen A3 this very strong move with
idea A5 to break
a white pound chain and a white doesn't
have time
uh
to trap the queen
Rook B1 is not working because of A5 and
after obviously
black has restaurant Queen C1 move
so rock B1
is not working
and how to defend out of
A5 move
Bishop G7 here
is also doesn't work
because a black has excellent shot A5
anyway because Bishop takes A5 is bad
here
black has
very strong
sacrifice
Rook takes A5 btx A5 Bishop takes C5
and now
because of
like
a pain on the diagonal E1 A5
uh White I cannot save his Knight on CS3
for example
if he plays Queen G3 then simply green
takes A5 engine another thread Bishop A6
and after
92 94
now black queens because
there is no
defense out of Bishop A6 move
so
here
it seems that the only
good possibility is to play Bishop G6
but after Bishop takes D6 C takes D6
okay so upon G6
white pound on G6 is weak and
a black
has a good contrary chances here
so 96 was also possible but as I said
before
I decided to go uh to the line plate
by Andrew Chang
Tran to show
a very nice idea
I played E6
before A5 C3
Bishop G7
and here the idea of Bishop G7
is to play
8X before
she takes before B6
ah
even in the pound back and to get very
good
way
an idea two
this also everything was played in the
under tongue game
it it's
before she takes before B6
B6
Bishop takes before
Bishop C7
Queen 7 it seems that uh
White's position is excellent very
strong pound on B7 on B6
uh White even can win
tonight
might be it after B7
and under 10
played B7 here
okay three
uh Bishop takes B8
Bishop A4
Queen C1
also uh if white plays
Bishop E5 here then this idea be it
green then Queen takes B7 uh White has
extra
uh a piece here but black
is very well developed his pieces are
extremely strong
I need to just K7 to bring another Rook
into the play
and it's very hard to
finish wise development
so here
position is still very unclear and there
are
many just a computer lines which
is it's impossible to calculate
everything during the game
for example after Queen bavan here
black
you can play D4 this just computer
computers move
ah after a bishop takes D4 there is
another
move E5
you can check everything
I will see your computers and after
Bishop takes E5 Bishop takes
G2 black has
a very strong compensation kin takes due
to
Queen D5
Bishop D4
q a
5 and now
uh he can
ah
make a draw after giving CS6
and
white has extra
piece and a black uh is forced to make a
draw here
okay uh
so
this was one of the lines in the game uh
Andrew tank
played Queen C1 it was his game versus
Australian Grandmaster Smirnoff
and after King C1
Queen takes B7
Bishop F5
was played also there are few or more
moves in this position but
the
not so good so Queen C7 is wasn't
because of Bishop T is D2
and after uh they only remove kidney too
because a king takes G2 is impossible
because of green B2
win the game
if Akinator here then simply
green B5
can F3
Queen before
and now
the threat of a checkmate
forces white to give up on the peace he
has to play you can see eight King seven
check
and after Bishop G7
he has to play to give up the piece and
uh black has winning position
so Queen C7
is bad here
in the game uh
under the tank played Bishop E5
Knight E4
Knight gf3
Castle
restaurant threat Roxy 8 and Roxy 2
and their tongue plate Bishop B2
Roxette
now if Queen B2 then Rook C2
Queen D4 take take and here even
black
can play it can take only two with uh
either with a rock or
there is a bishop
um his position is completely winning
so Queen B2 is bad
Queen B1
uh
here a black plate F6
in the game
tank Smirnoff
and this move else y to
finish his development in this position
avoid his extra piece and he can give up
this extra piece but after Castle
white has very good
position because now
uh after Knight takes D2
uh Knight takes due to F takes
E5 there is a western move Bishop G4
and a white I won that game
and when I analyzed this
entire variation
I went to this position and
I paid attention that or black has
excellent idea here which means
the game immediately
uh can any anybody
find this very nice idea idea
can you write in the chat please
what black can do
Bishop she told is possible but uh
what about the queen B2
is protected on between Bishop on E5
and it's unclear how to uh
the web develop Black's initiative
okay I can show you this idea a very
nice idea
ah if
a bishop takes due to then Knight takes
D2
you should start
with Knight takes D2 instead yes Knight
takes D2
after F6 is this possible but it will be
a similar position uh like it was in the
game a tank uh Smirnoff after F6 there
is Castle
and now
after F6 E5 Bishop G4 and this position
happened in the game tank smirnov and
white one now White
uh
has finished
development and he has very very good
chances
so
what do you think what is
uh Black's idea
here
the the main uh very nice idea was
Bishop takes D2 check
s the two
and now suddenly a black
wins immediately
he has excellent move rugby three
after this there is no anyway
how to save the game
for example if
y takes with a pound then after Queen
before
the only move is King D1
otherwise
attack industry a bishop B5 checkmate
so King D1
white case to give up the queen
and here after F6
now white still has material advantage
but
blacks pieces black blacks
green and rock are very strong and
also after F6 mission
G4 E5
Bishop G4
black has simply roxy2
Our Winning
Bishop on D4 winning material also the
castle is
not not
allowed here because white Kings has
already moved
in a White's position is hopeless
so if
White
that they can obviously with a queen
then after Rook C1 Bishop C4
uh
position is not so
I mean for black as it was before but
also black has excellent chances for a
win
also after obviously Bishop C3
is possible
but also black has
a much better position here
for example he can
start I guess D4 Bishop takes D4
check currency 3 green G5
trying to win pound on G2 so black has
a great initiative here and his position
is almost winning
so when I found this idea I decided
to go to this line uh in the
game versus max zugi
but when uh we got this position
uh
Max
uh was thinking uh
for a long time and uh probably here
felt that
I prepared something here and he decided
to play Knight G to F3 instead of B7
after this
uh
black has
also a good initiative
I played Bishop A4
and here another
wise opportunity he can play
either green C1 or queen B1
and also
there is
a queen takes A4 Queen sacrifice
and
I I had a big advantage in this game
because everything
as I analyzed at home with a computer
and when Max
uh
was thinking in this position it was
very hard to calculate uh not only
calculate but also evaluate the position
then he can get in a few moves
so he decided to sacrifice the queen
queen takes A4
but also
Queen C1 or queen B1
were possible
but in in this case
despite a very strong pound on B6
blackheads are good chances
in the game after Castle A3
black and simply played Bishop G6
probably this is the simplest way to
equalize
ah
they take
green before
27
now
if
Right Place 95 then Queen B7
a white uh his time to finish his
development but he does he have time to
protect Pawn on B6 and after Knight G7
Knight takes D7 Knight takes D7 Rook B1
Rook FB
ah black
Vince bound B6
and
he has a very good bound structure and
easy play so a black
at least black can equalize
as position
the similar line is with
a Quincy one
okay so S3 Bishop G6
Bishop B2
take on C7
take take
Knight bg7 cancel Rook a seven Rook C1
Rook C8
uh Black Queen spawn
on C7
and then game is
approximately equal even with
slightly better chances for black
because he has
might be weak
so
after Queen C1 and queen B1 black could
equalize but Max decided to play for a
win with Queen sacrifice
King takes A4
Rook takes A4 Bishop B5
Knight fd7
take on F4 Castle
what to do with white
here I need to
finish his development
for example if he plays Castle
what uh White could do
what will you do for white
tell anybody
all right there's a chat
okay Blake has a very restaurant uh move
Knight takes B6 here
in the pound
on B6
because now after Bishop takes B6 uh
Bishop G2
Knight takes D2
even before
this triple
attack on both Bishops and the Knight
and uh
black has extra material
here
so after Castle it seems that
white is forced to capture on G7 to
avoid Knight takes B6
G7
A4
trying
to defend pound on B6 with another pound
A4
Knight S6
this Knight is very important uh
from Black
now after
Knight E5
play it in the game
a green
E7 96
Queen C5
also it was possible can F6 move but
here white has
additional chances he can cancel and he
can give up the
piece right and now white case was two
very strong
a past connected pounds Bishop F5
clean G5 Bishop F4
so it's unclear how
black can get uh winning chances
so I decided to play for win in this
position
instead of Queen F6
I played Queen C5
taken before taken before
and here Knight takes C7 is a thread and
also
White
let's give time
to
finish his development
the night
on J2 is Kenyan
so
white plate rugby one also uh kinetu
here is not helping
to finish development
because after kinda two there is a clean
a deformo
and after Knight F3
Queen C4
King G2 Knight C5
blackheads Western attack and another
sacrifice
Knight B3 is very strong threat and
another uh
sacrifice
getting very strong
to postpone with two minor pieces versus
a queen
is not Captain White because after
Knight D4 there is very strong
opportunity Queen before
King D1
is the only move
and now another very strong shot E5
so
white cannot give up his B6 power he has
to play
Knight B2 but after
Queen B2
black
is just in time to create his counter
play
for example after A5 he has a very
strong deform move
now the three is a thread and after
Bishop takes E5 roxy8
attack in the night
on C2
and after the only move Roxy one
another shot Queen B5 now the threat is
Queen G3 check
and after Bishop takes D4
King G3
white does have time to promote his
Pawns
and black simply has extra Queen B7 is
impossible because of Queen B1 and A6
it's all after A6 uh white also versus
hispan a after uh
few checks
so
Marx decided to play B1 here
Queen A5
uh the threat is just to take Bishop on
G6
Bishop D6
Rook gate
Bishop G3
ah this position ah
was in my home preparation
before the game
and uh
now you can see how important can be
this preparation how important is
to find some good idea is the variation
which
your opponent can play in the game
first of all you can save
a lot of a lot of energy and the second
opponents
uh cannot calculate
all variations
during the game
over the board
it's necessary
to
have computers help and such
crazy positions
and here I play D4
and probably a white I should try to
give up
his Knight on G2 because
but to finish his development uh
he could try
a castle a queen
takes the two Rook fd1
and after that uh White can promote his
spawn uh be even in the Knight on A6 and
white can try uh to create Fortress with
broken Bishop versus queen
on the
response on the king side
so I think that it was
almost the last chance to escape this
game but Max decided to keep
I can see in the center for a while
protection Night on YouTube he played E4
after this
his threat is to play B7 then maybe B
and if white tries to capture Pawn on A4
then white will have time to Castle
so what to do for black
first of all it's necessary
to restrict a white Bishop on G3
so I played E5
again
it was possible to give up
the night and I finish development but
now very important is a pound G
for example after Castle
vintage D2
D3
for example Bishop B7
Bishop C7
Rock date B7 and in this position uh
the status be it but black has
another shot here
to create
a square for the kin
and at the same time black can attack
white Pawn
there is F5 move
restaurant move and after that
for example Bishop F5 btx F takes E4
Queen
F7 and black has a winning position
with extra Queen
so max played B7 instead
F6
another
idea here after F6 uh probably I can
play
G5
to prevent F4 uh
and uh
white Bishop on G3 will be in jail
forever
so white played F4
rugby
F takes A5 F takes E5 and finally
hit guess here
again up the Knight
but now it's too late also uh
kineto was possible
another a chance
and but after kineto black has
One More Shot
what the white can do could do here what
do you think
anybody
can suggest suggest a move here
please write in the chat
it's not before it is possible correct
but
uh
after night before probably uh White can
play
something like Knight C4
Tran told in pound only five also uh
probably a Black's position is also uh
much better but black has
a better move yes D3
G3 is the best move here
now after
Akinator three
night before is
decisive because
here
uh Rock days before
then simply uh
green takes before
uh also a 25 Checkers even better but if
a knight takes E5 then
white black has an ic5 move
and after Knight F3 simply Knight takes
B7 continuing attack
on the king
and also a black
has decisive material advantage here
so that's why white plate
queso take
Bishop E5 but now I don't need to keep
the piece on the
I played
Ro Cafe
uh Knight
is Guardian uh BH square and the best
what the white can get is
uh position with Rogue and Bishop
versus queen but d
uh black G pound is decisive here
white plate
Knight D1 Queen is three and G3
there is no way
how to defend
black played
a white plate
Bishop G6
and now
I could keep my Rook on the edge ring
but
after for example Rook 8 E5 is unclear
how to
uh
continue
to win my rock is needed here
in the attack I played Rook F2 creating
another thread besides
uh protection
base Square
uh
a rock is not necessary but on F2 it's
very strong piece now Queen takes E4
is a threat obvious imagine
attack also there is another setup I can
put Power on G2 Rook E2 and then rookie
one
no Venom
the game
so in the game I was played by Bishop G3
rookie to
Queen
Knight takes
Rook taste
cleaners can F7
uh
here
it was played uh Rook G1
also after rugby seven
black and play King G6
1
G2 rugby one and
how to win the game bishop and G3 is
protection E1 Square both Strokes also
practicing A1 Square
and now white is ready to
push his Pawn
a A5 A6 and try and
to
promote his Pawn after okay one and to
create some threads uh what is the way
for black how he can
now continue how he can win
what do you think
anybody please
write in the chat what is your
suggestion
if a context E4 yes this rocket G to the
thread but what to do after okay one
I am protected pound and A4 and also
trying to push my Pawn A5 A6 A7
as quickly as possible
but probably Queen E4 is also winning
that the best
move here is to play H5
what's this and what's this idea of HFI
move
yes H5 is the best move but what is the
idea of this move
and uh yeah remove the bishop but uh
what is the way
for example if I play A5 here
King G5 then
maybe I I can
play A6 H4
and take yeah
King G5
A6 H4 right
and here uh
the problem is this anyway opinion but
if I take take
yeah this rookie one is winning yeah
probably this also okay but uh after
H5 A5 uh black
is not needed to play King G5 he can
play H4 immediately
all right and after Bishop takes H4 q
and F4 uh now the bishop is Kenyan
Rook
uh
take G2 is not a threat because white
takes on YouTube with a check but there
is no square for the now why I Bishop
except of G3 he cannot defend it with G3
but after a bishop G3
now Rock Tage G2
is possible and also uh you you cannot
uh so you can uh
move your rock from B1 with the check
Rook B6 but anyway after 18 H7 now D1 is
a straight after Rook Place G2 so D1
yes William
so this is the easiest way to be an H4
take can takes E4 and or octave G2 black
beans in the game
Max play Drop G1 I took on E4 A5 D2
now
or
rookie one is the thread
as well as uh Rock Tech G2
white plate
Rock date kidney seven
and uh
White Rock does have squares on a g file
after G6 I played
Queen 3 and then snow defense out of
rookie one
uh move
so you see a
H how important was home preparation
and sometimes you can
prepare something special in the where
where a rare line
which is not very popular
of course Bishop F4 line is very popular
now but this particular line
uh happened just in a few games
and it was very helpful for me to
analyze everything before the game using
computer help
and also to find all
ideas
in this position
yeah also uh
the your a few games played after this
game and uh black
uh
was able to prove that his position is
where
uh
good and here black short
very nice results I hear black one
almost
all his games play played in this line
and uh it also it was very important to
have a good preparation
because ah the your opponent cannot be
sure
that you didn't
find
an engine calculate all variations with
computer help
so you see that in the game white tried
to give it from the main lines for
example it was a very important
moment when
instead of
playing
for some small advantage in in this
position
what
I decided to sacrifice his Queen
because
here I could not calculate all
variations and it was very hard to
evaluate a position which
a white couldn't get after this
sacrifice
and this is
the way how you can prepare to the
particular game
when you know
what your opinion plays usually and you
can prepare a big surprise for him
so
uh I think that the this
example was quite helpful for you and
you can use
this knowledge in your games in the
future
okay thank you for joining us
and see you next time
[Music]